a genome browser provides a way for us
to view a genome sequence along with
various pieces of information or
features that have been identified in
that sequence you are probably most
familiar with the term browser in the
context of an internet browser such as
Safari Chrome or Firefox that provides a
way for us to access and search for
websites on the Internet the genome
browser works similarly for genome
sequences the genome browser we are
using allows us to view the genome
assemblies of Drosophila or fruit fly
species although our work for these
modules will be focused on Drosophila
melanogaster the most commonly used
species in the laboratory let's take a
look at the various things we can view
using a genome browser navigate to the
genome browser by typing Gander w us TL
edu and clicking on the genome browser
link on the left side of the page this
will take you to the Gateway page at the
gateway page let's click to reset the
browser user interface settings to their
defaults after we do this we need to
choose which genome we want to
investigate choose the dimalanta gaster
genome and the July 2014
gene assembly we will be looking at
contig 1 after we hit submit we are
brought to the view of this region at
the top of this page we see the name of
the species and the assembly and the
position should show contig 1 colon 1
through 11,000 this means that we are
viewing 11,000 base pairs of the
Drosophila melanogaster genome we can
see the base pair numbers along the row
called scale let's first hit the hide
all button so we can choose which
features of the genome we want to view
we use the term features in
bioinformatics as a catch-all term for
anything associated with the genome each
of these features can be
elated or displayed along with the
genome sequence as a track that can be
viewed in the browser we can turn on and
turn off various tracks and also adjust
how each is displayed let's look at a
few features start by clicking on the
base position link under mapping and
sequencing tracks by clicking on this we
can view a description of this
particular track and change its settings
if we wish as the description states the
base position feature in the genome
browser annotations track image shows
the genomic coordinates of the displayed
region and when zoomed into the base
level you can see the nucleotides within
that region the description also tells
us more about how to view the individual
bases let's go back to the browser by
clicking the back button and view this
track right now the base position is set
at dents we can't see individual bases
because we are too zoomed out let's zoom
in to the first 100 base pairs of this
genomic sequence by typing contig 1
colon 1 through 100 into the position
flash search box after we hit return we
are now able to see the individual bases
of one strand of the DNA sequence a's
t's c's and g's if you click on the
arrow below the scale contig 1 label you
can see the strand that is complementary
to the top strand in other words the
bottom strand click the arrow one more
time to view the top strand again let's
change the base position track to full
to see more information associated with
this feature click full and hit refresh
below the bases we now see grey boxes
these indicate the amino acids that are
called for by each codon or set of 3
bases there are 3 rows of these boxes
because there are 3 possible reading
frames depending on which bases used to
begin the first codon in other words
where the reading frame is
published so the first reading frame at
the top starts with a very first base of
the sequence the second reading frame
starts with the second base and the
third frame with the third base for each
strand of DNA there are three possible
reading frames so there are a total of
six possible reading frames because DNA
is double-stranded some boxes are
labeled green these are for the amino
acid methionine translation always
starts at a codon that codes for
methionine which almost always has the
sequence ATG the red boxes indicate stop
codons
for example taa calls for an end to
translation let's look at another
feature the genes that are located in
this region of the genome let's zoom out
to view the entire region by typing in
contig 1 colon 1 through 11,000 in the
position / search box notice that we no
longer see the bases or amino acids
there is not enough room to draw all the
nucleotides and amino acids let's turn
on the fly based gene track to pack this
shows us the location of genes as
indicated by boxes and lines the names
of the genes are located to the left of
each graphical representation of the
gene with the gene name shown to the
left of the - this shows us that there
are 3 genes in this region of the genome
CG 3 2 1 65 SPD 2 and trah for these
modules we will be spending most of our
time learning about the Trojan